[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking about the divergence
the gradient and the curl
these vector calculus operations that
we're going to use to describe
physical systems and partial
differential equations
in the last lecture we talked about the
gradient operator and now we're going to
zoom into the divergence operator
and this one is really really useful for
studying things like fluid flows
compressible or incompressible fluid
flows
and a lot of other other applications to
the divergence so i'm going to jump
right in
remember that this
nabla or dell operator
if i write down del
in two dimensions that is a vector of
partial derivatives partial partial x
and partial partial y in the second
component so it's a two component vector
field the first component is a
derivative in the x direction the second
component is the derivative in the y
direction
and the gradient
would apply this del operator to a
scalar function f which would then
create a vector-valued function of the
partial derivatives
but the divergence notice we're taking
the dot product of this vector of
partials and so we're going to take the
dot product with a vector-valued
function f
so if we have some vector-valued
function f we'll call it f bar
and we'll say that that has components
f1
and f2
and in general f1 would be a function of
x and y and f2 would be a function of x
and y i might drop this dependence in a
little bit
then we can take the
divergence of f or the del dot f just
like you would normally do a dot product
of two vectors this is a vector and this
is a vector and so if i take
sometimes we call this div for the
divergence of f
and that equals
del
dot
f
and that equals
the partial partial x of f1
so partial f1
partial x
plus
partial partial y of f2
plus partial
f2
partial y
now remember when i had a scalar
function just a single scalar function
of x and y if i took its gradient
i created a vector valued function
and similarly with the divergence if i
have if i take the dot product of del
with a vector valued function the dot
product of two vectors is a scalar and
so i take my vector valued function and
its divergence is a scalar valued
function this is just a scalar function
which is the sum of these two partial
derivatives
okay
and this is really really useful this
essentially i'll show you in pictures in
a minute in some examples
this quantity here tells you how much
that vector field f this f is a vector
field it tells you how much that vector
field is locally sourcing out or sinking
in kind of pulling material in or
blowing material out
and if the divergence is zero
then there's no net kind of you know
local compression or compressibility
of that vector field
so we'll talk about this in a little bit
i want to point out just like the
gradient operator is a linear operator
the divergence is also a linear operator
so
maybe i'll just write that out very very
explicitly so
div
is linear
and what this means is that if i take
the uh
the divergence of the sum of two vector
fields f let's call it a
plus f
b
that equals
the uh divergence of f a
plus the divergence of f
b
uh and so on and so forth so you can
verify this yourself kind of just try uh
try this out and you'll see that this
this definitely does add in a linear way
similarly the divergence of a constant
times f a is just that constant times
the divergence of f a
and so this operator is linear
which means that the sum of solutions is
also a solution which is is kind of nice
so this we're going to use these as
building blocks for partial differential
equations later and those pdes if we
build them out of these building blocks
will be linear partial differential
equations
okay good so i want to give you some
examples of this divergence just to give
you some intuition for
for what this means physically so i have
three examples i'm going to walk you
through
and those three examples are pretty
simple so here's what i'm going to do
let's write down the vector field for
example one
so example
one
we're going to have our vector field
f
of x and y is going to equal
x in the i direction
plus y
in the j direction so this is i'm just
going to write these in lots of
different ways so you get comfortable
going back and forth between
this kind of unit vector notation or
this column vector notation uh so
similarly this would be written as x
and y
okay that's what i mean to have x in the
i direction and y in the j direction
it's a vector like this
and so what that means is that at every
point x and y there is a vector of
magnitude and direction given by this
vector here so let's let's actually draw
this out
so if i look at
the x y coordinates
then what i can do is at every point x
and y i can draw the vector
given by this vector field so at the x
equals one y equals zero point right
here there is a vector pointing in the
one zero direction so like this
similarly in the zero one direction
there's a vector pointing up in the
negative one direction pointing out
and so on and so forth at the one one
point i have a vector that is one one so
going in the x and the y direction
and it looks kind of like this so you
get this idea that everything's kind of
moving out away from the origin in this
and so our intuition is that the
divergence of this vector field should
be positive because things are diverging
away from from the origin
so let's actually compute
this this divergence here
so we'll compute div of f
the divergence of f
is equal to
uh partial f1 partial x that's just one
plus partial f2 partial y that's also
one so this is like partial x partial x
plus partial y
partial y
equals 1 plus 1
equals 2.
so what we say is that this flow has a
positive divergence or
the flow is diverging that's kind of how
we would say it this flow is diverging
and another way to think about this
is that if i had a little blob of you
know a little patch of material here and
this was a fluid flow in the ocean this
is a little oil slick and this is the
the fluid flow in the ocean
then if i if i integrate that patch of
particles forward in time i flow it
along the fluid flow
that patch is going to get bigger
by a certain amount
and it's in fact going to get bigger you
know in an amount that's related to the
divergence okay so a positive divergence
means that little patches are locally
going to get bigger or kind of expand
and a negative divergence would mean the
opposite patches are going to contract
or shrink okay so you can think of this
like a little point oil spill and things
are going to source out from that
okay let's do another example so the
other example i want to do
is kind of the exact opposite case where
we have a converging or negative
divergence vector field
so we'll have the same f
x and y
equals and now in this case we're going
to say it equals minus x in the i
direction
minus y in the j direction
and so we've literally all we've done
is changed all of the arrows all of the
directions of these arrows so now my
points are moving in
in a way that is kind of proportional to
x and y
at those points
and again if i'm farther out if i'm at
negative 2 negative 2 then my point is
moving in even faster and so that's also
important to draw that these are kind of
from farther away they actually
accelerate in
okay good so let's again go through the
motions of computing this divergence i
just want you to get very comfortable
doing these vector operations so the
divergence is just the dot product of
this partial derivative vector with this
vector field f1 f2 and so let's do that
the divergence of f in this case is
again partial
minus x partial x
so partial
minus x with respect to x
plus partial minus y
with respect to y
and that equals negative 1 plus negative
1
equals negative 2.
maybe i'll box these
okay and so
in this case essentially if we just
change the direction of our vector field
so instead of everything kind of blowing
out things are sinking in
i have a negative divergence and we say
that this flow is converging so this one
was diverging and this one is converging
okay or it's a compressible flow things
are compressing
and again if i take my little patch now
i'm going to start with a patch kind of
out here i have a big patch
and if i flow that big patch forward in
time it's going to shrink
by a factor that's related to this
divergence
this this negative 2 here okay
so that's really really useful this kind
of divergence being positive means our
volumes grow divergence
negative means our volumes contract
and for the last example i'm going to
show you a vector field that has
divergence zero
and we'll see that the kind of volume of
these
patches stays the same so that's the
third example example 3
is a flow with divergence 0.
maybe i'm giving away the punch line so
this vector field i think it's going to
be minus y
in the i direction plus x in the j
direction so this one's a little
different
than these in these vector fields
the
x component was equal to x and the y
component was equal to y but here
they're kind of switched
so this equals
minus y
x
and now i'm going to draw this vector
field
here so again if i want to draw this
vector field
given by by f
arrow
i literally just take test points and i
evaluate what is this vector at all of
those test points so at the one zero
point when x is one and y is zero
this vector is zero one which points up
so right here my vector field is
pointing up
in the zero one position when x is zero
and y is one
this is a negative 1 0 vector so it's
pointing in the left direction negative
1
in the x direction 0 in the y direction
and so on and so forth if i'm here it's
pointing down if i'm here it's pointing
to the right if i'm farther out it's
twice as big so i get this kind of thing
going on here
it's a little hard to draw these if i'm
at some diagonal point here it's kind of
moving
diagonally like this
so that's what this flow flow looks like
and uh we'll compute the um
the divergence of this to confirm that
it's zero and then we'll drop our test
patch and see what happens to that test
patch
okay so the divergence of f
the divergence of f
is equal to
partial f1 partial x
so that is partial
negative y with respect to x
plus partial f2
which is x
with respect to y
and now you know partial y with respect
to x is zero partial x with respect to y
is zero
and so this vector field has zero
divergence it is divergence free i'm
going to write that down so this is
called a divergence
divergence
free
vector field okay very important type of
a vector field
and one of the kind of intuitive pieces
is that a divergence free vector field
is characterized entirely by rotation
so it's not sourcing or sinking it's
only rotating
and so again if i take my little patch
here let's put a little patch right here
this patch
doesn't get
stretched or or shrinks
it just rotates around this flow
literally just kind of is a solid body
rotation and it just after some amount
of time
moves that patch so it stays the same
but rotates over
okay
and so this is a nice example of a
divergence free vector field so this one
has positive divergence this one has
negative divergence and this one has
divergence free
okay good so those are three examples of
the divergence there's a couple things i
want to show you here because i think
this is really really useful
is that
when i have a vector field like this
this
f
arrow
you can think of these vector fields as
establishing a differential equation
so this uh this differential equation
here if i take this
this f bar of x and y
let's just rewrite this as a
differential equation
so what i can do is i can think of how a
particle will
flow or move around in this vector field
and this is a very useful perspective
in systems
so i can write d dt
of my point x y
equals
f bar of x and y
and in that case it equals
this vector field here so in matrix
notation it would be one
zero zero one
times x
and y
okay
and we're normally we're used to seeing
this kind of linear systems of equations
from differential equations
so that's one way you can think of these
vector fields these vector fields are
essentially the right hand side of a
differential equation for what a
particle would do in that vector field
so this field of vectors if i drop my
little red particle or pink particle
here i can integrate this
differential equation to find out where
it goes
and then here of course you see that the
solution
is going to be
x maybe i'll just write it down here
x
and y
at time t
is going to equal
e to the t
x naught
and e to the t
times y naught
and so you kind of have this uh this
this growth of these initial conditions
they expand uh and they accelerate away
from that initial condition
okay good uh and maybe what i'll do in a
future lecture is i'll relate this
quantity this divergence quantity
to uh kind of these exponential
expansion of particles um because that's
that there's a rigorous way of
connecting this
uh divergence quantity and kind of the
exponential expansion rate of particles
in these vector fields
okay um let's just recap so we're
talking about the divergence
which is the dot product of my dell or
nabla operator with a vector-valued
function
and again when i take the dot product of
two vectors i get a scalar so the
divergence of a vector-valued function
is a scalar function it's just a scalar
in this case it was a constant because
my vector field was linear
if i
made this an x
squared here
then this would be uh
partial minus x squared partial x would
be
minus two x
minus one
and the divergence would actually be a
function of x so my but it's still a
scalar function it's not a vector
function it's a scalar function of x and
y
and it can quantify locally in my vector
field is my particle expanding is it
contracting or is it just doing kind of
a solid body rotation with divergence
free
now the last last last thing i want to
show you
is what happens if i take a scalar
function so remember i can take the
gradient
of a scalar function so i can take my
regular old scalar function f
and if i take the gradient of it now i
have a vector valued function
so this would be
a vector function partial
f1 partial x
partial f2
partial x
and so what if i take the divergence of
the gradient
so if i take the divergence
of the gradient
of a function f
then essentially what this equals is
partial partial x
partial partial y
dot product with partial f uh sorry this
is just f
because this is a scalar
i really botched this up
pardon me
this is partial f partial x and partial
f partial y because f is a scalar and so
this is
this is the gradient
partial of partial x partial f partial y
and if i compute this dot product
remember the dot product of of two
vectors is easy you just take the
product of the first two uh you know the
the first components of both of them
plus the product of the second
components of both of them
and now what i have is the second
partial derivative of f with respect to
x squared
plus the second partial derivative
of f with respect to y squared
so this is cool this is the sum of
second partial derivatives of f with
respect to x and y
and so the divergence of the gradient of
a scalar function f
is this quantity
this is called the laplacian of f this
is uh
del squared of f and it's also a scalar
value the laplacian
and this is going to come up all over
the place this is one of the most
important
linear differential operators in all of
physics this is how we're going to study
electrostatic potentials
uh incompressible irrotational fluid
flows this is an extremely extremely
important quantity i'll tell you all
about later kind of how to work partial
differential equations using this
operator but again
i just want you to be very comfortable
that you can use these building blocks
together if i have a scalar function i
can compute its gradient to get a vector
function
if i then take that vector valued
function i can compute the divergence of
it to get another scalar valued function
and that scalar valued function the div
of the grad of f is called the laplacian
and it's a very very useful uh useful
quantity
okay so i hope you're finding this
interesting we're about to so i'll tell
you about curl next time
kind of you know we'll actually look at
this example down here where this field
is divergence free but it's rotating so
we'll compute the curl next time
then we're going to start talking about
some kind of identities like gauss's
theorem stokes's theorem and how you can
use these building blocks to build
partial differential equations for
example laplace's equation what happens
if i say
del squared f equals zero this is a
partial differential equation it's a
differential equation with partial
derivatives
and the properties of f f will be a very
very special function if it satisfies
this partial differential equation
so that's all coming up soon stay tuned
and you're going to know you know tons
about pdes and vector calculus in a few
more lectures thank you